for the second day in a row a wreath
laid by a british minister outside the
kremlin walls the defense secretary with
his two top commanders in moscow to meet
his russian counterpart sergey shoigu
and the russian general chief of staff
it may well be that nothing comes of
this meeting the russians have been
pretty firm in their position that what
they do on their own territory is their
own business but at least there will
have been personal contacts made to the
two military men who have a direct line
to vladimir putin
[Music]
and if there was no breakthrough at
least a step in the right direction
what is incredibly important especially
at this time with over a hundred
thousand troops at high readiness on the
borders of another country is that we do
not get into a position of
miscalculation or escalation
and only through those type of
relationships and the ability to talk to
each other at times of concern
can we
pave the way for any de-escalatory
measures
as russia continues joint military
drills with belarus the u.s called an
urgent phone meeting with nato and eu
leaders
and warned again that an invasion could
come at any time
as we've said before
we are in the window when an invasion
could begin at any time should vladimir
putin decide to order it i will not
comment on the details of our
intelligence information but i do want
to be clear it could begin during the
olympics
despite a lot of speculation
that it would only happen after the
olympics
u.s citizens have been asked to leave
ukraine within the next 24 to 48 hours
and the uk has followed suit telling
british nationals to leave while
commercial means are still available
the u.s president making it clear that
he would not send in troops to save them
for fear of direct confrontation between
u.s and russian forces
that's a world war when americans and
russia start shooting at one another
we're in a very different world than
we've ever been in
sergey shoigu assured ben wallace as
russia has done over and over again that
he had no intention of invading ukraine
but it will be russia's actions not
words which count
dana magnay sky news moscow